so wir erleben gerade wirklich einen
echten anti lauf das muss man so sagen
pandemie und dann auch noch
rekord-inflation alles wird teurer jetzt
benennen sich schon die ersten 1 euro
shops um in zwei euro shops macht ja
auch sinn im november 5,2 prozent
inflation so hoch wie zuletzt nach der
wiedervereinigung
wahnsinn überall gehen die preise durch
die decke energiekosten vor allem gas
lebensmittel möbel benzin und jetzt
freunde jetzt wirds aber richtig bitter
nicht nur die energie und spritpreise
steigen auch für bier müssen die
deutschen künftig tiefer in die tasche
greifen
wenn inflation persönlich wird der
bierpreis geht hoch wo ist der
krisenstab wenn man ihn braucht
rohstoffe wie braugerste sind bis zu 50
prozent teurer
wahrscheinlich sieht ein klassisches
herrengedeck in der kneipe band so aus
die brauereien geben halt ihre höheren
kosten und zweiter beispiel diese holz
euro paletten auf denen man bierkästen
transportiert die kosten viermal so viel
wie im letzten jahr aber hier dafür hat
krombacher sich jetzt etwas tolles
einfallen lassen und zwar für jeden
kasten bier wird ab sofort ein
quadratmeter regenwald komplett
abgeholzt um daraus dann europaletten
herzustellen ja sorry liebe orang utans
aber man muss halt prioritäten setzen
und gerade am emotionalen thema bier
erkennt man schnell inflation betrifft
uns alle ab zwei prozent wird es
ungemütlich und dann müsste die
europäische zentralbank ezb geleitet von
der stets braun gebrannten christine
lagarde eigentlich irgendwann eingreifen
schließlich ist preisstabilität ja der
wichtigste auftrag der ezb also
theoretisch praktisch machte lagarde
aktuell gar nichts eine ihrer direktorin
verspricht immerhin wachsam zu sein
um frühzeitig zu erkennen wenn es eben
doch entwicklung gibt die darauf
hindeuten dass wir mittelfristig eine zu
hohe inflation haben könnten im moment
ist es halt so dass wir eine zu niedrige
inflation sehen eine zu niedrige
inflation auf dauer gesehen
zu niedrig 5,2 prozent von meinem geld
verschwinden jeden monat aber ihr ist es
zu niedrig ist ja schön sie meint wird
im nächsten jahr ist die inflation
bestimmt irgendwann niedriger und wenn
nicht gucken wir mal fakt ist gegen hohe
energiepreise oder kaputte lieferketten
hilft auch keine zinserhöhung das stimmt
das könnte den aufschwung hin bevor
omikron im kilt auf der anderen seite
selbst wenn zinsen erhöhen was brächte
geht das überhaupt noch es muss man
fragen angesichts von eu staaten deren
finanzierung derartig abhängig ist vom
billigen geld ja das ist ja so auch der
deutsche staat hat sich sehr daran
gewöhnt von anlegern geld zu kriegen
dafür dass sie ihm geld leihen dürfen
der private sparer blutet also leise
weiter und träumt von früher
viele sparer lassen sich immer noch von
banken und sparkassen mit der
niedrigsten zins abspeisen mit zurzeit
fünfeinhalb prozent
bitte jemand soll ich mit fünfeinhalb
prozent abspeisen wird mir gnadenlos 5
prozent rein ich habe es verdient
gott 100 milliarden euro haben deutsche
sparer zusätzlich im corona jahr 2020
auf die seite gepackt und jetzt schmilzt
das bei den meisten so weg in der
todeszelle zwischen inflation und
negativzinsen werden sie wohl allein
dieses jahr 116 milliarden verlieren
negativzinsen bzw war entgelte sind
inzwischen leider völlig normal rund
jede dritte bank verlangt solche
strafgebühren weil wir so unverschämt
sind den unser geld aufzudrängen hier
hilferuf eines bankers wir werden seit
mehreren jahren geflutet will ich nicht
sagen aber schon mit zweistelligen
wachstum im bereich von kurzfristigen
geldanlagen und das ist zu viel das ist
so viel die leute schießen und zu mit
ihren blöden geld was sollen wir mit
geld wir sind eine bank tja klassisches
sparen macht in diesen tagen wirklich
keine mehr spaß
einfach sinnlos gerade für
geringverdiener aber denen immobilien
oder aktien nicht in frage kommen ist
das eine sehr bedrohliche entwicklung
oder auf werbe deutsch
[Musik]
ja ist ja so was soll man machen was
kann man machen also man kann zb weil
weil sie nicht 30 banken je 100 euro
einzahlen damit keine strafe fällig wird
und muss aber gleichzeitig höllisch
aufpassen dass einem die kreditinstitute
nicht irgendwelche quatsch produkte
andrehen wie diesem 88-jährigen sparer
hier angeboten wird dem vater ein
investmentfond und ein bausparvertrag
mit stolzen zehn jahren laufzeit und
letzte rate ist am 11
bist du ganze 98 jahre alte schafs
und wo ist bitte das problem kann auch
mit 98 alles schön auf den kopf hauen
und dann ausbauen also nicht
negativzinsen sind tatsächlich eine
zumutung denn die bank kassiert ja für
ihre eigentliche dienstleistung sowieso
gebühren wir schauen mal live zu
matthias matschke erleidet direkt hier
um die ecke eine kleine bank filiale
herr matschie rechtfertigt man dass es
gibt außer negativzinsen keine gebühr
für die ich absolut keine gegenleistung
kriege ja also dafür ja direkt beginn so
viele fehler in einer frage erst mal
nehmen wir keine negativzinsen wir
nehmen ein so genanntes verwarnt geld
denkt viel schöner man sagt ja auch
nicht mehr schutz geld sondern
italienische kulturabgabe und was heißt
bitte keine gegenleistung bei uns gibt's
kugelschreiber umsonst
kugelschreiber
also natürlich nicht für jeden sie
müssen schon in einen unserer
aktienfonds investieren oder keine
ahnung eine völlig überflüssige
lebensversicherung kaufen alles bloß
kein geld eins sein scheiße
hallo ich
wollte 1000 euro auf mein sparbuch tun
hier ist nicht unser weg
alle fünf minuten kommt hier so ein
müllmann ein gewackelt und velemir seine
eigenen reichsmark andrehen erde an
sparer wir wollen euer geld nicht euer
geld stinkt richtig sie schicken ja
sogar drohbriefe an bestandskunden
akzeptiert strafzinsen oder wir kündigen
euch jetzt reicht's aber wirklich was ja
für drohbriefe das sind ganz normale
anschreiben ich habe zufällig ein star
wir haben dein geld gibt es ab sonst
passiert was wo ist das denn bitte ein
drogerie außerdem wir zahlen doch selber
0,5 prozent strafzins an die ezb das
müssen wir doch an irgendwen weitergeben
naja also erstens neben ja einige
geldinstitute inzwischen mehr als 0,5
prozent und zweitens habt ihr ja im
gegensatz zu uns bei der ezb freibeträge
das heißt geld wird nicht einfach nur
durch gereicht da verdient jemand dran
und ich sag mal so ich bin es nicht eine
stichprobe des portals finanzszene zeigt
etwa die hälfte aller banken verdient an
den strafzinsen mehr als sie bei der ezb
verlieren ja entschuldigung dass wir
gerne geld verdienen mea culpa mea culpa
warum arbeitet man denn wohl in der bank
weil man geld mag und genau da liegt das
problem in dieser verdammten niedrigzins
welt hier der ehemalige chef der
commerzbank bringt es in hoch
emotionalen worten auf den punkt unser
thema und dass der gesamten branche ist
wir verdienen einfach nicht genug geld
klar ein paar tricks haben wir schon
auch drauf wir leihen uns zb bei der ezb
geld für minus ein prozent zinsen
wegen das für 0,5 irgendwo anders an und
können die differenz behalten also
banken können dass menschen natürlich
nicht da es wäre quatsch
ich würde gerne ein girokonto eröffnen
okay ganz ruhig dass hier wird keine
einfache du willst jetzt ein dreckiges
geld ist das langsam raus und bringt es
zu der anlage bank dann passiert keinen
was matthias matschke
und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe fans der feinsten unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere videos
sehen wollt
das war super tag
wir haben ich sehe auch echt clique aus
heute